the xfl provided us with a great example
of transparency even though it came from
an obvious blunder there is pj walker
texans quarter not texans houston
roughnecks quarterback taking a knee on
fourth down with three seconds left
right at his own twenty that's where the
seattle dragon should have had the ball
with a chance to tie even though they're
down nine you could score a touchdown
and go for three and tie it up
and the game ended there was still three
seconds on the clock the game ended the
xfl issued a statement acknowledging the
mistake and this is something you never
see the nfl do chris here's the
statement
saturday's seattle dragon's houston
roughnecks game should not have ended as
it did replays showed clearly that the
knee of pj walker touched the field
rendering him down and the fourth down
play officially completed with
approximately two seconds left on the
clock effectively turning the ball over
to seattle on downs with a nine point
differential seattle was denied an
opportunity to tie the game the xfl
sincerely regrets this error in addition
wes booker who served as officiating
supervisor for saturday's game has been
reassigned the nfl
never does that no matter how big the
screw up there is never that kind of
public admission
and it's great do it everybody knows so
do it you gain credibility when you
acknowledge a mistake like that good for
the xfl and i hope the nfl is paying
attention yeah i'm not i'm uh i'm with
you i mean it is it is good for the xfl
i get that it's a good example for all
sports really to be that transparent on
the ball right after you make a mistake
like that put out a statement i mean yes
the nfl seems reluctant to do that now
they did
they like they did it after our our rams
our ram saints nfc championship game but
they did no they didn't it was all it
was all very it was very sad i just
talked
so we don't need to issue a statement
because we admitted to sean payton and
sean payton opened his mouth about it
that was it's stupid come out and admit
it when you make a mistake you're not
going to make the mistake go away you're
going to make people at least say we
appreciate the fact that you were honest
about what all of us have recognized and
witnessed right so you want the nfl to
have a little cute little quote card
like the xfl did this yes and when i get
it i think it would go over a long way
you're right well then why are you
demeaning it by saying cute little quote
card well i don't agree with him well i
don't know being dismissive because
we're talking about the xfl and we're
talking about a bunch of people who
couldn't manage the last five seconds of
a game
throwing the ball into the air he took a
kneel with three seconds all right so
that's my issue i mean did they not
watch the super bowl and mahomes threw
the ball in the air is to lose the last
three seconds okay that's all that's why
i was going that's it that's a good
point okay and and beyond that beyond
that uh i of all the mistakes the nfl
has made from an officiating standpoint
over the years i can't imagine number
one the officials declaring the game
over with time left on the clock and
number two thank you everyone dispersing
and no one's saying get your asses back
out on the field we still have one more
snap and that was wes booker's and and
look here's where transparency can go
wrong
because wes was interviewed by steve
levy in real time i wish we could play
it it was not impressive at all wes and
this is why i think wes booker's getting
reassigned because of his explanation
not because of the decision because
wes booker said well yeah it should have
been two seconds left uh we went back
and looked at it but the game was
already over so there was nothing we
could do
and and steve levy's like what are you
talking about everybody's still here the
officials just ran off the field it
could make a difference in a team season
and the guy's like yeah i guess it could
but there's we're gonna look at it but
there's nothing we can do oh yeah so yes
right so good new good news is they were
transparent bad news is there's still
some kinds of work
there's a few things that got to work
out still about yes all right you hate
the xf how can you hate it when you've
never watched it i watch it
i don't hate it i'm just not buying it
yet
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports